hi i'm mike coleman a developer advocate
here at google cloud and in this video i
want to talk to you about how you manage
your applications
after you've migrated them using migrate
for anthos
[Music]
getting your application containerized
is just the first step
you'll also need to consider how you
manage that application going forward
how do you handle base operating system
updates
application patching and other day two
tasks
the rest of this video aims to answer
some of those questions
as a quick side note i'm not going to
spend a lot of time talking about how
container images are constructed
if you're not familiar with that topic
pause the video
go check out the documentation on the
docker site and come back and rejoin me
also if you're not familiar with migrate
for anthos check out our earlier videos
where we provide an overview of the
service
as well as how to perform an actual
migration you can find a link to those
in the description below with that being
said
let's take a look at how migrant for
anthos creates the container image for a
migrated application
migrate for anthos automatically
examines a source vm and extracts the
workloads running there
into their own container images when
looking at the ongoing management of
those containers it's important to
understand
how their images are actually built the
container that you run in production is
a combination of two
intermediate images the first one is the
migrate for anthos runtime layer
and the other is what we refer to as the
non-runnable system layer
the non-runnable system layer contains
the extracted portion of your migrated
workloads
and will serve as the base for all
future updates
as the name implies this layer by itself
doesn't do anything
it's only by combining it with the
migrate for anthos runtime layer that
you get a container image
that you can deploy into production so
let's look at the docker files so you
can see how this works in practice
now the docker file uses a multi-stage
build to combine the two
artifacts together this first from
statement tells docker to use the
migrate for anthos 1.6.0 runtime image
from the google container registry
and to refer to it going forward as
quote unquote
migrate for anthos runtime the next from
tells the dockerfile to use the image
that was generated when you ran your
migration
it's also stored up in the google
container registry under your project
notice that docker will refer to this
image as quote unquote source content
as an aside while i am specifically
using google container registry in this
example
depending on where you're migrating from
we can also use aws's
elastic container registry or a local
registry
this section is where you'd run any
updates and we're going to cover that in
more detail in the next section
so for now we'll just skip over it
this line tells docker to copy the file
system starting at the root from the
migrate for anthos runtime
into the container image now remember
that the container image we're copying
into
is the source content image so
basically this command copies the
runtime container image
into the source content image and the
last line tells the container to run the
v2k.go script and start your migrated
application
now as i've said this docker file is
what's used to create the migrated
application configuration that you
initially deploy after running migrate
for anthos
but what do you do if down the road you
need to
update the image for some reason for
example you need to
install an updated dependency or patch
your application or
upgrade the underlying migrate for
anthos runtime
going back to our docker file now
updating the migrate for anthos runtime
is
actually pretty simple you just go back
to that first from line and you update
the version
if you need to update any part of your
application including system or language
libraries or the application code itself
you would do that after the second from
statement so for instance
if i'm a node developer i might copy in
a new package.json
and run npm install to update some of
the packages
my application is using or i could copy
in a new app.js file to update my actual
application code
the underlying file system in the
container is the same as what you had in
your vm
so you would just update the files in
their original locations
now from here you could manually run
docker build to create an
updated image push that to gcr and then
roll out the new version of your
application
but manually building the new container
images could become tedious
if you are regularly processing updates
a better approach is to use a tool like
cloud build
to automate the process with a modern
cicd pipeline
by leveraging a tool like cloud build
you can define triggers such that
whenever a change is pushed to your
source code repository
a new container image is created and
once that new image is created
you can perform manual or automated
tests
and then finally using either manual or
automated processes
you can push that code out into
production
let's take a look at how we would
implement a pipeline in practice
i'm going to construct a simple pipeline
that will connect to my github repo
such that when i push a new change to
github a new container image will be
pushed up to gcr
from there i'll update my kubernetes
yaml and roll that updated app into
production
okay so let's go ahead here we're going
to start in cloud build and i want to
show you the trigger that i built
earlier remember a trigger is something
that can kick off uh via different
processes so we have a
trigger here that when i push to a
branch in my github repo here to do
cloud build
um where i've installed the github app
for cloud build
when i hit the master branch with an
update it's going to go ahead
and run a docker file and it's going to
do that
in the root of the repository looking
for a file called dockerfile
and it's going to build us a new image
that is tagged with the short sha
of the build process right so that'll be
our unique tag
and then if we look down here below what
we can see is the actual docker file
built or the docker build command
where we're going to build that and
we're going to point to that docker file
that i just mentioned so that's what's
going to happen whenever i push a change
to my repo
now this is the docker file we talked
about this earlier in the video
you can see here is the run time here is
the non-runnable base that is created as
part of the migration process and then
what i've added to it
if we come down here is i'm basically
saying copy the
contents of this repo into user source
to
do in the container right in the
container image and that's where it
locate was located in the vm
that's where it was the code was located
in the container as well then they're
the same
so now what i want to do is i want to
come up and i want to actually go ahead
and make a change to my source code so
i'm going to come up here
into this show task
file up here at the top and i'm going to
click here and i'm going to go in
and i'm not running these on vms so it's
not a host it's actually a pod
so let me change this to pod and then i
will save this file out
and then i will move down here into the
terminal and i'll do a git add
star to add the change file i'll commit
that to the repo with a commit message
of use
update host string and then i'll go
ahead and do a push
now this push will kick off that trigger
that we just talked about so if i come
into history
you can see it's already building so
we'll come in here
and i'll show you here a second when
this comes up you can actually see
there's that commit message i
i used update host string this is gonna
take a bit so let me pause the video and
i'll rejoin you when it's done
okay so we've finished up here and if we
come down we can see
uh there's where we copied the source
code into the image as i mentioned
and here's that short sha and we're
going to use that
to do the update to our application so
let's go to the image repository here
container registry look at the images
and
that's where the non-runnable base gets
stored by the migration process
and there's the to do directory that is
where we actually get our deployable
applications so there's the one we just
created
and now we're going to deploy that by
opening up a cloud shell
and editing the kubernetes yaml file so
let's open this up
and we're going to move into the
directory where the artifacts are stored
and we're going to edit the deployment
spec.yaml
and we're just going to scroll down here
and we're going to change that
tag on the image name to the one we just
created
we're going to save that out and then
we're going to go into the terminal
and we're going to go ahead and well
before we do that let me point this out
so it says serve by host that's what
we're going to change
so now let me go here and i want to go
ahead and
um clear the screen and then we'll do a
coupe ctl apply
minus f deployment spec.yaml and that's
going to update
the stateful set with a new image let's
do a get pods with a watch so we can
watch that happen
and while that's happening i want to
just talk about a couple of things
one this is not exactly what you would
do right there would be a step between
building the image
and deploying it and that would involve
some sort of testing right we talked
about that and the other thing
is um you could automate this step if
you wanted to right
in the video we don't really have time
to go through that process but
um you could fully automate this so you
automate your testing you automate the
uh sign-offs and the release and then
you automate the push to production
uh here we're just basically automating
the building of the container image
we're assuming a manual
uh test step and a manual deployment
step all right so we're almost done here
the container should be up and running
in just a couple seconds
and looks like it's just about done so
let's go ahead and check on that
application and see if our change got
reflected so we'll come up here click on
to do list
app and you can see down here actually
there it is it's now served by a pod
instead of a host so the application has
been updated so in this video
we talked about how you can use a cloud
build build trigger uh connected to a
github repo
to automate the creation or the updating
of your migrated
applications that about wraps it up for
this video i hope you found it useful
if you want more information on
migrateforanthos we have some additional
videos posted here on youtube so check
those out
and then head on over to cloud.google
migrate anthos to learn more
you